getting back to the eyewitness account I  think it is believed that those are some  of the more convincing accounts right  because you're basically saying the  radar data shouldn't should count as  eyewitness data right you're saying The  Operators are testifying we don't have  the raw data we don't have the time  series data as you might expect correct  so we don't have data that we can  actually analyze and do some kind of  reconstruction we have people's  Recollections of it which is certainly  more than just eyewitness uh you know  eyeballs on the thing we have people  talking about the radar for example when  fraver went out to see an object he was  sent to a location because there was a  radar return at that location and it was  one of these uh you know in the Nimitz  encounter they had these groups of five  radar returns which were slowly drifting  down from the north to the South which  they initially thought might be some  kind of glitch in the system